ich bin letztens zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben bis ins Glas im Flugzeug
geflogen und das nicht mal Langstrecke
sondern von Mallorca zurück nach
Düsseldorf die Airline condor bietet
hier nämlich einmal pro Tag ein Flug im
Airbus A330 an eigentlich ein
Langstreckenflugzeug also komplett
ausgestattete Business Class erstmal
ging es für mich am Flughafen Palma de
Mallorca in die Lounge habe ich ein
bisschen gefrühstückt und dann war auch
schon Boarding und so sah das Ganze aus
die Tickets oneway kostet zwischen 150
und 700 €. ich habe für meinen Rückflug
205 € bezahlt man hat auf jeden Fall
jede Menge Platz ein Sitz mit
Massagefunktion als Begrüßungsgetränk
gab es einen Orangensaft und ziemlich
viel essen das war auf jeden Fall der
entspannte Flug meines Lebens und für
das Geld würde ich jederzeit wieder
machen nächste Woche fliege ich nach
Thailand und natürlich mit Business das
war ein Spaß noch mal